okay everyone a new trailer for ant-man
and the wasp dropped this week it's on
the shorter side shorter huh with a few
new shots of the villain ghosts a woman
who can face shift through solid
surfaces very cool and there's some
banter between Scot Hank and hope
interestingly the trailer ends with
Scott Lang saying oh also we got to save
the world that's major can't forget that
now sure that could just be a joke about
how every super heroes task is pretty
much to save the world but in the
context of the ending of infinity war
Scott might not be too far off so how
exactly will ant-man see people
connected those events it's pretty clear
that ant-man the wasp will at least be
set before infinity war it's just not
likely that Scott and the rest would
care that much about ghosts and silly
car chases and shrinking down buildings
into luggage if half of the freaking
world had just been snapped out of
existence right like that's an
apocalyptic situation civilized society
would be losing their minds but it is
still possible that the ending of
ant-man the wasp could tie into infinity
war like we've speculated the pass of a
final scene of the movie or maybe a
post-credits scene could feature
characters in Scotts world suddenly
interesting element from ant-man has
that he has contributed to the MCU is
the quantum realm remember that's a
subatomic dimension that exists beyond
time and space it's where Janet Van Dyne
the original original wasp is still
missing the movie will focus on their
search for her now access to a dimension
beyond time and space sounds like it
could give ant-man and the wasp especial
edge against Thanos and Avengers 4 if
that is going that way or if you believe
in the theory that the characters have
faded away at the end of the war were
actually just transported to another
parallel dimension maybe the quantum
realm could serve as a way you can go
between those dimensions allowing a man
to like rescue people and bring them
back what do you guys think what are
some ways that like ant-man could
connect to infinity war can you match
and if that's like the the Tony has
about saving the universe like oh we got
to save the world to like you get
outside and you see somebody like
sweeping up like a bunch of stuff off
the ground you're like Oh little dark
he's just he's just joking and shrinking
and having a great time flying on with a
with wasp it's I'm hoping that we that's
post-credit I'm hoping that the movie is
contained enough that we can just still
get a story and it doesn't have to
literally end with that no it's
definitely gonna be post
yeah I'm gonna put money down on that
right here I'm announcing it get ready
six bucks
now the question will it be comedic will
it be dark like what's his daughter's
name Cassie Cassie or will it be kind of
a joke like maybe some one of his
buddies Michael piñas character could be
fade away as he's telling the story
maybe like Hank I think that would add
some stakes for hope I mean not that she
would need any but something that would
have personal stake in that so yeah
she's motivated to join the Avengers and
come help out like that Scott yeah right
he could dust out maybe but we have seen
some onset stuff with him and the other
Avengers so maybe it's hard to it's
really hard to know because you hear all
these things of like some people are
confirmed for actors for who have faded
away but yeah
but I do like your idea of like if he is
gonna help I hope it's something
specific to any man's powers and not
that thing where you kind of just like
packs a wallop sometimes out of nowhere
like that yeah that's a very basic usage
of in that I almost feel like include
them or not like you don't have to
include them if you do find a clever way
to use them and I think we all know it's
getting small enough to get behind the
stones and pushing this or crawling in
this ear and I'm super excited about the
Cointreau just because it seems so
cosmic for a movie that seems anything
but that seems pretty practical and like
rounded like going into this whole other
realm that seems almost dr. strange Ian
I would love to see if that like if
there's some kind of very specific way
that he can connect with the people have
faded away through the quantum realm
don't know that I buy that because the
quantum realm is supposed to be this
idea of like beyond subatomic so it's
it's in existence and we're just going
to the most basic forms of our existence
but then it just something about that
logics I see that line down of like
shrinking I don't see why the alternate
realities we're gonna have their own
quantum realm but it's a circle it like
it funnels down and all of reality is
within a circle that creates a portal
back and you know there's another side
that's how the cornermen realm works in
our world so if they're writers were
good I feel like maybe he shrinks down
hit official theory he shrinks down into
the soul stone that would be kind of
cool with those whole worlds in there
and maybe we don't have a direct way of
like getting to it and that could be a
place that
that could be a way that he helps out
because ant-man has shrunken to cosmic
level things in the comics it's always
been very cool the way they played
around with that kind of stuff and I
feel like that'd be a good way to get
him to help out in some way it's and a
lot of people do believe that that is
where the souls of the people faded away
or contained they're contained within
the soul stone that's one idea that
people have so maybe that gives like
people like and want them to have a
backup copy everyone I just don't know
that they're so like even if it's their
souls and what makes them corporeal
again that's the question we all have
[Laughter]
ghosts poison get in line we're gonna
try to get you in the same one it's like
a it's like an assembly line it's like
skin soul stay in it soul guys run away
quick because people are coming out
quick well comment down below to tell us
your theories about how ant-man could be
part of infinity war or if you think he
won't survive to see the day of Avengers
4 and reminder to subscribe to new rock
stars for all of our deeper analysis
about the Marvel Cinematic Universe
thanks everybody